Leo Kuchwalek ist vielleicht der älteste
Schwimmlehrer der Welt.
Einmal pro Woche kommt er
in die Schwimmhalle in Berlin-Lichterfelde.
Hier vergisst er,
dass er in diesem Jahr
102 Jahre alt geworden ist.
Denn Schwimmen ist
seine große Leidenschaft.
Die Lebensfreude hängt auch
damit zusammen,
dass ich regelmäßig Sport treibe.
Und sie sind vermutlich ein weiterer Grund für
seine Langlebigkeit und seine Vitalität.
Früher hat Leo Kuchwalek
als Schlosser gearbeitet.
Als er vor 40 Jahren in Rente ging,
wollte er seine freie Zeit sinnvoll nutzen.
Er macht[e] eine Ausbildung
zum Schwimmlehrer.
Seitdem bringt Leo Kuchwalek
Berliner Kindern das Schwimmen bei.
Die Freude selbst mit den Kindern zu haben –
alles ehrenamtlich.
Mehr als tausend Kinder haben mittlerweile
bei ihm die ersten Schwimmzüge gelernt.
Dass ihr Lehrer ein Hundertjähriger ist,
gefällt ihnen.
Wie alt ist Leo?
102.
Er hilft alle[n] und
hat auch sehr viel Geduld ... mit uns.
Das ist wirklich cool, dass wir einen Lehrer
haben, der 102 Jahre alt ist.
Ich mag es, dass wir so einen
alten Lehrer haben.
Seine Kollegen bewundern ihn.
Da sind wir auch sehr stolz drauf
und dass er wirklich noch so topfit ist
für sein Alter
... weil er hat immer noch Humor.
Er kann wunderbar mit den Kindern
umgehen, und das hält ihn jung.
Jung geblieben ist ja ’n bisschen übertrieben,
aber ...
Aber in der Seele schon.
In der Seele, ja.
Ich kann jeden Quatsch praktisch mitmachen.
Ich will ja noch ’n bisschen älter werden.
Ich bin noch nicht so alt.
Vielleicht hat das mit seinen Schülern zu tun.
Die erwarten, dass er ins Wasser springt.
Jeden Donnerstag. Solange es geht.
So, jetzt springen Sie mal rein.
Ich schaffe es nicht.
Ich bin ja früher von fünf Meter[n]
gesprungen. Wiedersehen erst mal!